[Music]
orange skies all on my feet
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
humans
[Music]
[Laughter]
politicians got me moving cockroach
scapegoat migrants into sunk boats
while they spend our taxes on some top
coat
chopping down the forest till we cough
smoke add it up add it up cause the sun
grows
they say african nations got corrupt
laws
why they giving contracts to their
uncles
do they think we're stupid yet they must
do
they won't change their ways until we
bust through
[Music]
is about time
cause of black people on the front line
ain't you seeing what i'm seeing
hurricanes and fires blazing flooding in
savannah basins we were all indigenous
until they slave that's time to break
decisions
[Music]
[Laughter]
a puzzle to this piece
[Music]
if i let my mind have money boo i would
increase the rhyming truths they got our
people by the wombs they got our people
by the bulls left show coming it's time
to move that's true coming it's time to
move in the world entitled my better
[ __ ] to rely to better move your health
to actual belief in science is vital
educate yourself from an expert who do
you see when they like her better get
your kid around her tip is not getting
better quick you take them to an expert
doctor not a youtube clip so come on
yes you should question things but
that's science but when you tell people
not to question that science
not saying that's lies but we between
lines
they would love to keep you ignorant
fine
cool in tucson revolution
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah
mother nature calling me away
and humans are possible
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
mother nature me
[Music]
[Music]
nice